Happy New Year iran-backed terrorists
attacked the US Embassy in Baghdad on
New Year's Eve but decisive leadership
dispelled the violence we will examine
why Baghdad didn't turn into Benghazi
and what it means as we look forward to
the coming decade then speaking of
violence the Pope smacks a woman's hand
for grabbing him to forcefully good for
him we analyzed the Pope's lap heard
round the world
a trans man gives birth using female
sperm according to the British media and
Anderson Cooper muses on the biggest
phalluses in Hollywood on CNN finally
the mailbag all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
happy new year we begin this new year on
a somber note we lost a real one
just moments ago who Leon Castro dropped
out of the 2020 Democratic presidential
field pour one out for who Leon he was a
real one
my favorite candidate in the race and
now he's gone I was on Leland Vitter's
show on Fox News the as Julian Castro
announced that he was running for
president and Leland asked me for my
reaction and I told him what I ate for
breakfast that morning it was some sort
of omelet and I told him that was more
consequential news than who Leon Castro
entering the presidential race and turns
out I was right but I do want to
commemorate his candidacy because the
candidacy of who Leon Castro took
political correctness to the furthest
extreme we've ever seen in presidential
politics this was during I believe it
was the second Democratic presidential
debate when he said he didn't merely
support reproductive freedom he
supported reproductive justice and not
just for women
he supported abortion rights for trans
women as well meaning biological men
people without uterus people who could
never ever possibly have an abortion
that was who Leon Castro's campaign and
it only got more outrageous and
ridiculous from there I am seriously
going to miss him in this presidential
race who Leon really hope that you run
again next time so that we can enjoy
this all over again we will get to the
biggest news of the decade and there's
only been two days so far in this decade
first I got to thank our friends over at
expressvpn I can say with full
confidence hundred percent confidence
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here's why expressvpn does not log your
data okay there are a lot of pretty
cheap or free VPNs and had the way that
they make money is by selling your data
to ad companies expressvpn does not do
that expressvpn also is extremely
inexpensive but it's just enough that
they're not going to sell your data and
and put all of your data in compromising
positions
speed is the other reason other VPNs are
just slower okay many will slow your
connection down or make your device
sluggish not expressvpn my internet
speeds are blazing fast with expressvpn
and it's just super easy to use
unlike other VPNs you don't have to
input that input in or get this program
going you just fire up the app takes one
click of a button you connect it's so
easy even your grandparents could use it
everybody admits this to TechRadar the
verge seen that many other tech experts
rate expressvpn the number one VPN in
the world look you know if you're
listening to this program you listen to
Cu you may be tuned into some pretty
weird stuff on the internet okay you
fire up that incognito window you look
at some things you don't want people to
see if you know what I'm talking about
like daily wire.com so protect yourself
with a VPN I trust expressvpn comm /
michael mi CH AE l go there today get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package expressvpn comm / michael visit
expressvpn comm / michael to learn more
in the news beyond poor who leon
dropping out of the race the year
started off in a pretty auspicious way
pretty it was actually a pretty good
start to the year why there was an
attack on the US Embassy that's not a
good start well the good start was the
response and it shows you the difference
between the 2020s between right now and
say the Obama administration
maybe there's a difference in these two
decades on new year's eve iran backed
terrorists tried to attack the US
embassy in baghdad this was a replay of
the Benghazi attack on September 11th
2011 you remember that during the Obama
administration in Libya there was attack
on the US Embassy four Americans killed
including the ambassador it was an
absolute disaster when the militants
started to attack nobody responded there
was no reaction from the political
leadership in Washington they just let
the the consulate be attacked over there
and unfortunately these Americans died
and then there was a cover-up afterward
Barack Obama sent his National Security
Advisor on national television to lie
about the the attack they said that it
was a spontaneous up
caused by a YouTube video that virtually
nobody had seen of course it wasn't that
it was a terrorist plotted planned and
executed attack and it led to years of
investigations Hillary Clinton famously
testified about it and said who cares
what difference does it at this point
doesn't make if they were terrorists or
YouTube video demonstrators who cares
it's no big deal and of course it does
matter it does matter this attack in
Baghdad failed because of decisive
leadership so what happened is hundreds
of terrorists of militiamen and their
supporters showed up to this embassy in
Baghdad they broke into the compound
they destroyed a reception area they
smashed windows smashed up the whole
building put graffiti all over the walls
this was to protest US airstrikes
against an Iran backed militia that
ended up killing 25 terrorists so now
they're protesting this there's going to
be a response because the United States
is fighting with Iran through these
proxies now why didn't it turn into this
disaster of Benghazi it didn't turn in
because the u.s. responded immediately
and yesterday the the militiamen the
terrorists withdrew they withdrew after
two days of clashes with American
security forces because the minute the
attack began the United States sent in a
hundred Marines the United States sent
in 750 paratroopers to the region they
deployed troops out there and they said
you are not taking our embassy and of
course eventually after that show force
the terrorists withdrew President Trump
was asked about this on New Year's Eve
at mar-a-lago so he's there in his
tuxedo looking great by the way and
Milani is standing there looking
significantly better than just like the
picture of elegance and grace and
they're being asked about this attack
and Trump has one clear message for the
terrorists for the international
community and for the American people he
says this will not be another Benghazi
I think it's been handled very well the
Marines came in we had some great
warriors coming
and do a fantastic job and they were
there instantaneously as soon as we
heard
I used the word immediately they came
immediately and it's in great shape as
you know this will not be a Benghazi
Benghazi should never have happened this
will never ever be a Benghazi but we
have some of our greatest warriors there
they got in there very quickly as soon
as we saw there was a potential for
problem they got in and there was no
problem whatsoever I also want to thank
the Iraqi government they really stepped
up I spoke to the Prime Minister today I
thanked him but they stepped up very
nicely
all right this story tells you two
important things it shows you for one
the absolute corruption of the media
which was basically taking the side of
the terrorists and sort of lamenting the
fact that this wasn't turning into
Benghazi there was that's the first part
the second thing it shows you is the
importance of political leadership it
shows you something that I predict will
possibly define this decade which is the
importance of taking control of your own
political destiny the ability of us to
use our will to use our decision-making
powers to come in and take control of
our political destiny we are not simply
leaving ourselves up to circumstance we
have the ability to shape our political
future we'll get to both of those in a
second we'll read the New York Times
this take on it they the New York Times
they outdid themselves on this attack
and Bank in Baghdad first I got to thank
our friends over at route insurance
route insurance ask a simple question
what if good drivers didn't have to pay
for bad drivers that's the question you
know you're you're subsidizing bad
drivers I know all of you listening to
the show you're excellent drivers of
course so you're you're subsidizing bad
drivers well route insurance developed a
mobile app that measures driving
behavior and what it does is by removing
bad drivers from the equation routes
saved good drivers up to 52% in 2019 5-2
that's a huge number more than a half
52% route was the fastest growing direct
insurance company in the United States
how does it work route bases their rates
Merilee on how you drive not who you are
now what boxes you checkout but how you
actually drive your route insurance card
is available right from your phone and
if you get into an accident you can file
a claim directly in the app takes two
seconds this is a model of insurance
that just makes sense so instead of the
kind of old model of you know you they
come up with a number based on certain
check check boxes that you tick off you
just put this app in you are measured on
your driving and you can save a lot of
money all you have to do is download the
route insurance app drive normally for a
few weeks during the route test drive
see how much you can say if give a route
a try there's no reason not to give them
a try go to the App Store download the
route insurance app sign up in less than
minutes start your test drive today that
is Roo t download the route app today or
visit join route com to learn more and
see how much you can save root reserves
the right to refuse to quote any
individual a premium rate for the
insurance advertised here in savings
based on national reviews reported by
actual customers form1 not available in
all states this product is not available
in California drats
what this attack in Bagdad shows you is
the corruption of the media and that we
have the ability to form our own
political future so the New York Times
when they're responding to this
initially takes the side of the
terrorists I don't think that's an
overstatement here's what they tweeted
you decide for yourself
quote hundreds of Iraqi mourners tried
to storm the US Embassy in Baghdad
shouting down down USA in response to
deadly American strikes this week that
killed 25 fighters first of all who are
the fighters the fighters are
iran-backed terrorists they're fighters
they though I use the word terrorist
they use the word fighter there were US
airstrikes against terrorists good
that's a win and then in response a
group of mourners showed up to attack
the US Embassy first of all I don't
think they were mourners okay because
when I think of mourners I think of
people wearing all black crying sort of
just sad and dejected possibly
despairing that's not what these guys
were doing in Baghdad what they were
doing in Baghdad was busting down the
door to the compound to try to kill
Americans those aren't mourners this
reminds me of when the Washington Post
ran an obituary on Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
the head of Isis and it described him as
austere religious scholar not a
terrorist not an absolute gang leader
the the leader of one of the biggest
death cults in modern history no no he
was an austere religious scholar and
these terrorists in Baghdad were
mourners okay that's the media for you
joy Reid was upset she was she was
hoping you could even read the
desperation as she was typing on Twitter
saying that this was gonna be Trump's
Benghazi and yet it wasn't why wasn't it
it wasn't because of the importance of
individuals of decision-making of
political leadership of our own free
will the left constantly tells you that
individuals don't really matter okay
individual decisions individual
leadership they tell us on the left that
history is moved by Great impersonal
forces circumstances dictate our destiny
the presidency is too big a job for any
one man you can't possibly ascribe a
responsibility to individual politicians
when you look at these great forces in
the world well if that's true then how
do you explain the difference between
Baghdad and Benghazi how do you do that
you can't I think this is the theme of
the 2020s I think the theme is going to
be people waking up and realizing hey
wait a second we're not just victims of
circumstance we're not just victims of a
sort of global consensus on the left and
the right Democrats and Republicans this
consensus that's gonna outsource our
jobs and get rid of our political
futures and destroy our our homes and
we're not just victims of social
circumstances cultural circumstances
that will destroy the family that take
away our constitutional rights we're not
we're going to say no we're gonna fight
back and look our decisions our own
leadership can have a positive effect
you know there was a church shooting
over Christmas and New Year's they're
shooting at West freeway Church of
Christ a drifter lunatic drug addict
showed up with a shotgun he came there
he was known to the congregation he had
mental issues he had drug issues all
right this guy had a long rap sheet he's
got a long criminal history and he
showed up with a shotgun
the very sad news is he got off a couple
shots and killed two members of the
congregation before anybody was able to
stand up now the the silver lining to
this the reason that he killed two
people instead of 240 people is that the
congregation was armed and a very
well-trained person who was a firearms
expert who was a firearms teacher got up
there
his name's Jack Wilson one single shot
he killed the shooter saved 240-250
lives right away now
the mainstream media were horrified by
this here's a USA Today
USA Today ran an op-ed here said armed
even in church Texas shooting is about a
lot more than Jack Wilson's heroism the
real story isn't heroism here right the
real story they write on Twitter quote
Jack Wilson is exactly the type of
person you want around with a gun
because he's also a firearms instructor
but we know nothing about the at least
six other parishioners who also appeared
to draw their handguns and that's
terrifying why is it terrifying what's
terrifying about it so you got seven
parishioners pull out their guns the
minute this guy starts shooting because
he's going to try to pick off the whole
congregation like sitting ducks
and seven people pull out their guns one
person neutralizes the target and that's
it
it's not terrifying at all these people
all every single one of them used their
firearms responsibly they didn't just
start shooting left and right get in the
middle of a gunfight they pulled out
their guns this guy Jack Wilson was able
to take out the target immediately and
then they put their guns away that's a
wonderful thing these people took
control over their destiny they weren't
simply going to let the cruel and the
deranged run roughshod over their entire
congregation and kill 240 innocent
people this is this is a real silver
lining here I mean it's awful the loss
of any life to two lives is so so
terrible they saved two hundred and
forty there was a spate of of
anti-jewish attacks over the Christmas
break all threatened New York New Jersey
all all around that area in particular
now they haven't been reported on very
much these attacks because the
assailants weren't white guys generally
they
fit the media narrative the Trump is
unleashed this spate of white supremacy
neo nazism and so they've they've mostly
been out of the news but these were
these were major attacks I mean some
were killing some of them were just
assaults on the street but there were a
number of them how do we respond to this
I suspect religious conflict is going to
increase in the 2020s I think we're
looking at a decade of more intense
religious conflict because well all of
these religions are getting kind of
muddied you know the religion especially
of secular leftism
of environmentalism of gender ideology
these are religious movements and
they're very exclusive so you know just
to use environmentalism as a great
example
if you oppose environmentalism you're
accused of destroying the world
that's why we've had eco-terrorism for
the whole history of the
environmentalist movement on the fringes
you get eco-terrorism because it is such
an intense and exclusive religion but
this is true of other religions too
obviously we've had a lot of violence
from Islam in the past several decades
this is this is true you're seeing
rhetoric increase around gender ideology
if you if you oppose the gender ideology
you're called a bigot a hater denying
people human rights they're new laws
that are being passed to stop you from
that I think we're going to get a little
more conflict in this religious
ideological landscape now how do we
protect ourselves there's a simple
answer from the church shooting from the
attacks on Jews from all around which is
to arm yourself avail yourself of your
constitutional rights
take some responsibility take some
control David French tweeted this out
David French the writer formerly a
National Review now he's at The Dispatch
David French tweeted out hey one thing
you can do right away to protect
yourself is to get a gun and learn how
to shoot it people jumped on him on
Twitter and the recently jumped on him
is not just the guns okay it's not just
the idea that okay there's a Second
Amendment and I can use my gun to
protect myself everybody already knows
that the reason that people attack David
and other people who suggested arming
yourself is because of the sort of novel
idea over the last several years that
you have some control over your own
destiny and this is going to be a key
theme of the 2020s last decade people
were told that they were powerless we
the people were told we had no control
over our government over a trade over
our economy over our culture over our
future we're told we don't have any
power and then we realized we do there's
a movement going on not just in the
United States it's bigger than the u.s.
it's bigger than Trump it's going on
throughout the West where people realize
that we can take control of our
political destiny we'll get to what that
means in a second we'll get to a
transman giving birth or something I
don't you know good luck figuring that
one out and we'll even get to the pope's
lap but first we got to thank our
friends over a ring speaking of safety
and danger rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer now you probably
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery maybe there's a surprise
visitor you will get an alert you will
be able to see hear and speak to them
all from your phone that is thanks to
the HD video and two-way audio features
on ring devices I love ring you know I
give out ring to my friends as a
housewarming gift
because it gives you a peace of mind
okay obviously there's some times I've
had friends of mine who get the ring
alert and they're lying in bed it's 3:00
in the morning and they talk to people
who are trying to break into their home
that's the more serious version another
version of this happened friends of mine
they kept seeing some motion going on
they thought there was some one case in
the joint turns out it was a little
possum now they like their possum and
they leave a little food out for it to
all thanks to ring you just you just get
peace of mind all right when I'm on the
road I know that sweet little lace is a
pretty good shot but I don't want to
leave it up to chance I want to be able
to check in on my house on my home from
anywhere you should too with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camera the ring starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home how do
you how do you use it how do you get it
go to ring.com slash Knowles can or wles
that is ring.com slash normal scatter WL
e s
this is the story okay last decade the
Obama administration if you want to
tread neatly delineate the time last
decade we the people were told we were
powerless on our rights on our law on
our trade on our economy just to use
trade just use the example of trade we
were told there's just there's no way to
keep manufacturing jobs there's no way
it's impossible neither party is gonna
do it you can't how could you possibly
keep manufacturing jobs you just got to
go we've got to send all of our jobs
overseas we need to just buy cheap
consumer goods from China that are
produced with slave labor and then we've
got to live in tiny little pods and eat
bugs that's what we're gonna do because
we have no power over our so over our
lives of course not same thing with
immigration we're told there's no way to
slow down immigration we take in a
million illegal aliens a year and 1.2
million legal immigrants far more
generous than any other country in the
world by a long shot
there's no way to slow it down there's
no way to stop it you can't control who
comes in and out of your country
there's no way to slow down the
progressive destruction of our culture
and our rights no way to stop Obama
can't impeach him can't do anything the
Trump election was this prefiguring of
grabbing back our rights the Trump
election is often referred to as a
middle finger to the elites and the
bureaucrats and the technocrats and
that's true so what does that mean what
is the significance of that middle
finger that the significance is you
can't tell us what to do or you can't
tell us what to do forever and what has
happened as a result of taking back our
rights as the whole world fold apart
that's what fold apart has the whole
world fallen apart that's what we were
told was gonna happen
but that's not what happened things are
actually going great the economy is
going gangbusters we have we just found
out Trump has issued the fewest
regulations in 44 years this is a 44
year low the economy's doing great just
over Christmas economy soared consumer
confidence way way up we had a great
Christmas season manufacturing jobs have
returned again just to use that one
example we have some control even the
arguments over porn over the social
issues that kind of dominated the last
few weeks of 2019 they're about this
they're about the question can we take
back our political future can we decide
how to govern ourselves can we have a
spirit of an exalted freedom a social
freedom of
this weekend and I predict that the
2020s are going to be about reclaiming
control over our political future all
around the West because we know that
we're on the precipice all right we know
that things have have fallen apart
they've they've broken down to such a
point that we can't even say what a man
is and a woman is anymore we can't even
say that a baby is a baby we can't say
these basic things we can't say what
marriage is anymore
and that is too far we know it we know
how much we have to lose just to use
this example I love this story from the
mirror this is a UK tabloid the headline
is quote transgender man gives birth to
non-binary partners baby with female
sperm donor that is some holy on castro
level political correctness i don't what
let's try to break that down transgender
man okay so that's a woman gives birth
to non-binary partners baby okay i don't
know non-binary what does that mean with
female sperm donor now I'm no biologist
but last I checked there is no such
thing as female sperm so you read the
the article and it explains to you what
it really means proud dad Rubin sharp
today tells how he capitals gave birth
to a miracle baby in Britain's most
modern family the 39 year old
transitioned to a man 12 years ago but
he still had maternal instincts and six
years ago stopped taking testosterone in
the hope of one day having a child and
that dream came true when he and partner
Jay had a bouncing baby Jay is a
non-binary so does not identify his male
or female the sperm donor was a trans
woman and even the doctor was
transgender and while a handful of other
UK men have fallen pregnant after
transitioning from a woman Ruben and Jay
are among the first couples to speak out
about their remarkable journey except it
isn't remarkable the journey is not
remarkable because once you cut through
all the imaginary gender categories that
Britain apparently has embraced and
certainly this tabloid media have
embraced what you realize is it's not
that a transgender man gave birth to
non-binary partners maybe with females
what happened is a woman who now
identifies as a man but she's a woman
used sperm from a stranger to conceive a
baby and give birth which has happened
many many times there's nothing new
about that there's nothing particularly
interesting about that it's been going
on since the dawn of time a woman used
sperm from someone she didn't know very
well to conceive a child and give birth
it's the story of the human race now
there's a there's just a lie in the
headline they say that this transgender
man well I guess that the whole headline
is alive but they say the transgender
man gives birth to non-binary partner
put non-binary partners baby that's not
true the non-binary partner had
absolutely nothing to do with the
creation of this baby the headline would
be more honest if it said woman gives
birth to baby conceived with sperm from
a stranger and that woman also has a
girlfriend that's what happened but but
the gender categories make it so
confusing it doesn't have to be that
confusing alright there's nothing
unclear about this situation other than
all of the sort of ornamentation we've
put onto it all of this gender ideology
and this is the importance of clear
language because if you use the leftist
jargon then you can be convinced that a
man just conceived and gave birth using
female sperm that's a very strange world
to live in or you can just realize that
a woman gave birth as women always do
that's what's really happened it also
Britain this this also breaks down some
of this gender ideology because we've
we've defined man and woman down to be
absolutely nothing so we're now at the
point where a if a woman identifies as a
man but then says she wants to give
birth and menstruate and have a normal
female cycle she's still a man well if
that's true then what is a man I mean at
the very least the most basic definition
we had before of gender ideology was
that you are however
you identify but if you start
identifying as someone who menstruates
and and conceives a child and has a baby
surely you're no longer a man right I
mean what there is no definition that
could possibly fit this for men and for
women I looking forward at 20 20s I
think we're going to see a return to a
little bit of reality I think so much of
the pushback on leftism has been these
crazy metaphysical claims about men and
women and gender ideology and even
abortion the beginning of human life
what a human is a clump of cells I think
we just we see that it isn't true
and we see the disastrous effects of it
on our culture and we are we're ready to
be rid of it we're ready to return to
normal and reclaim some of our future
from these fantastical ideologues which
is something pretty hopeful when you're
looking at the next decade we will get
to the Pope slap heard around the world
we will get to Anderson Cooper referring
to the largest phalluses in Hollywood on
national television because CNN real
news serious journalism and we will get
to the mailbag first though based on
what we've seen so far 20/20 is shaping
up to be a pretty wild year as Democrats
rally to get rid of President Trump the
best way to stay informed on all things
2020 is to become a daily wire member
and get comprehensive news and opinion
from us on demand now because we know
that you need to stay up to date we are
giving you 20% off all memberships until
January 6 20 % off to celebrate 2020
when you use promo code DW 2020 members
get our articles add free access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show select bonus content access to the
mailbag and so much when you get so much
more plus our new all-access tear gets
you into live online Q&A discussions
with me with Ben with Drew with Matt
Walsh plus our sites writers and special
guests you ask we answer and the leftist
tears tumblr just fills right on up that
is promo code DW 2020 for 20% off until
Monday January 6th June today and stay
informed on all things
2020 we will be right back with a whole
lot more the Pope's lap the CNN Anderson
Cooper phallus discussion and the
mailbag head to Daly wire.com we'll be
right back
the Pope slap heard round the world we
have to get to it it has created quite a
lot of controversy online among
Christians among among Catholics
specifically even among conservatives
the Pope was meeting thousands of people
and he's going around and a woman
grabbed the Pope's hand his arm and
wouldn't let him go she Yanks him back
in and so he smacks it right on her hand
and and sort of chides her for grabbing
him so forcefully and then walks away
here is the clip I will I will narrate
it so the Pope he goes he pulls away she
Yanks it he's now and she won't let him
go and then he gives her a nice little
smack on the hand and walks away
he looks really kind of angry about it
he looks a little peeved because out
stop pulling me what are you doing stop
that lady and then he gets out of there
okay
was the Pope correct to act this way
some are saying was totally uncool
because on the one hand you have Christ
saying turn the other cheek and you know
give away your possessions and just live
to serve and on the other hand you have
Christ throwing people out of the temple
and overturning tables and whipping
people and saying go buy a sword and so
there's a little bit of debate on both
sides
certainly the Pope was within his rights
to chide this woman for what she was
doing I don't just mean this in a kind
of liberal individual autonomy my rights
my body my choice kind of way I mean
this as a matter of justice and prudence
and responsibility the woman has no
right to yank the Pope and for him to
just necessarily roll over okay if if
nuns at a Catholic school are able to
give you a little smack on the hand with
their ruler when you're misbehaving
surely the Pope can give you a little
smack on the hand when you're yanking
him and pulling his arm in and not
letting him get away it's perfectly
right perfectly just for him to do that
however the Pope should not have lost
his temper that is the real poor the
problem isn't the snack the woman needed
a little snack it can be very
encouraging to smack people on the
Bayeux Tapestry there's this famous
image Battle of Hastings of Bishop odo
wielding a club smacking these
retreating soldiers they're his own
soldiers and they're trying to retreat
and he's got a club and he's just
smacking them over the head and saying
go back there go back and fight and and
the other Bayeux Tapestry says here
Bishop odo wielding a club encourages
the boys so it can be encouraging and
supportive to give people a little smack
which is what the Pope was doing
however he should not have lost his
temper he should have given her that
little smack out of love and I think
that's the subtlety here that is being
lost in this whole debate is he looked
visibly angry and sort of marched away
and then he he apologized and I think he
probably should have apologized not for
the smack the woman deserved it and she
needed a little corrective to teach her
how to behave when the Pope is around
but because he lost his
temporary you shouldn't have done that
people make mistakes a good reminder
that the Pope is fallible except for the
very rare instances when he's infallible
and he apologized as he should have
before we get to the mailbag have to
talk about the biggest phalluses in
Hollywood or rather we have to talk
about the CNN journalist super serious
facts first this is real news describing
the biggest phalluses in hollywood on
CNN on live national television on new
year's eve here is Anderson Cooper
she turned to Anderson that said he's
not gonna ask me who has the biggest
leave of anyone I've ever been with
right no it was she turns to me out of
the blue and goes he's not gonna ask me
who has the biggest in Hollywood is he
okay that's what yeah and just said it
okay all right there he is just giggling
go ahead New Year's now the thing about
CNN's new year's coverage is that it's
always pretty degenerate these days the
hosts are doing shots on TV last year
there was a bunch of pot on TV during
CNN and now Anderson Cooper talking
about his very famous socialite mother
Gloria Vanderbilt and all the men she
slept with and who has the biggest
phallus in Hollywood I mentioned this
not to really attack Anderson Cooper or
CNN
I don't care nobody's watching it nobody
saw this live anyway other than the
people who had the misfortune of walking
through airports on New Year's Eve but I
do it to point out that CNN is not a
news channel there's a piece in national
review on this the other day
CNN is not a news channel it has no
credibility it has no standing it
obviously has no dignity it's a kind of
tabloid entertainment channel for
leftism on cable and it's pretty much
been that the whole time and now we can
see it okay and it's worth remembering
because when they air they're really
super serious journalism adds facts
first this is a banana we're real news
just remember that no you're not real
news you're the station we're Anderson
Cooper jokes about the biggest phallus
in Hollywood and calls conservative
Republicans tea baggers and I was
Anderson Cooper too and where Don Lemon
shows up and he looks super serious
right after he gets back from Murph's
and allegedly assaults people at bars
late at night
it's a
bunch of derelicts okay this is
newschannel it doesn't have that kind of
credibility now that's fine they provide
sort of tabloid cable entertainment okay
they've got an audience for that but
don't let them harangue you about real
news and serious journalism and the
separation of powers in our Constitution
they don't get to do that you talk about
the biggest phalluses in Hollywood and
you giggle about it while doing shots on
TV you lose that right which is fine
because I think it's kind of the theme
of the decade I mean if I had if you can
predict a theme of a decade that's what
it is
it's we the people looking forward
taking back some of our political
destiny taking back our culture taking
back our rights taking back our
seriousness of purpose and what happens
on the left of politicians on the left
are screaming about socialism and
soaking the rich and all this kind of
crazy cockamamie gender theory and on
the mainstream media you have them
giggling about phalluses okay that's
that's what they're doing they've
they've run their course and now I think
we with a little bit of hope or pivoting
back and taking control of our destiny
let's get to the mailbag before I have
to go from Ben hi Michael
happy new year I'm getting married on
August 30th this year to the love of my
life and I wanted to know what your
advice would be to a Christian couple
regarding the cultural environment how
do you navigate being in the world
without being a part of it thank you for
the excellent podcast and I hope to see
another fantastic book soon thank you
very much this one may even have words
in it the important lesson in my vast
experience as a married man is to
remember that there's no such thing as a
vacuum nature abhors a vacuum so you
cannot try to live virtuous upstanding
good Christian life by not doing the
things of this world you're that's not
going to work by not doing this not
looking at this not drinking that not
right you're not that's not going to
happen you were going to be able to
practice the virtues by actually
practicing the virtues by affirmatively
doing something so for in
since late at night when you're lying
around your apartment you could do a few
things you could binge eat right you
just sort of stuff your fat face you
could watch five million episodes of
some show on TV you could look at porn
getting back to our debate you know week
though in the last weeks of 2019 you
could drink yourself silly you could or
you could pray right those are all
activities that will take up I don't
call in half an hour to an hour late at
night and so it you can't you can't do
the culture you can't be virtuous you
can't practice the virtues by avoiding
you have to do something else and so
what I would recommend is you do those
things that are gonna make you in the
culture but not of it you know you're
gonna do those things that are allow you
to thrive in society but be living for
another place and maybe that means going
to church maybe that means praying maybe
that means availing yourself of the
sacraments maybe that means going to
confession
maybe that it means doing and so it's
very foreign in this culture we're all
we ever want to do is sort of sit around
and loaf and scroll on Instagram or
something but what you've got to do is
turn away from that Kanye West sang
about it in his new Jesus is King album
he said you got to put the gram away you
got even things that seem kind of
trivial like scrolling mindlessly on
your phone or something they can be
harmful you've got to do something else
have a conversation read a book go pray
go to church it sounds like you're
pretty proactive anyway and excited to
do that so I wish you the best of luck
and happy engagement from David a
Michael I'm a recent subscriber and a
big fan I'm debating a couple friends
currently about the morality of capital
punishment and they are saying that the
death penalty is immoral or at least
that we shouldn't use it because one it
is irreversible versus something life
like in prison and two in the New York
in the New Testament specifically using
John 8 Jesus wants us to have mercy what
are your thoughts also of note they
cited the Catholic catechism 2267 this
is this new change to the Catechism by
Pope Francis which says that the death
penalty is impermissible
although I'm not Catholic I'd appreciate
your thoughts on this as well thanks so
much okay yeah there's so much
misunderstanding about capital
punishment first of all your friends are
saying that capital punishment is bad
because it's irreversible unlike all
those other punishments say life in
prison but those are irreversible too if
you're stuck in prison for 35 years
because of bad evidence or something
those 35 years are gone you can't
reverse that it's just like capital
punishment is irreversible now you might
say at least you can get out of prison
and have a good five years before you
croak whereas with capital punishment
you can but what this speaks to and I
think the reason why opposition to
capital punishment is grown is because
of the advance of secularism we used to
believe from the dawn of time until just
about five minutes ago that this world
is not all that there is that the human
person has a soul that there is ultimate
justice that our justice comes from
divine justice that our laws come from
the natural law and that there will be a
judge and we will see him face to face
once we die I still believe that
religious people still believe that but
among the kind of shallow secular
culture that that is gone so I think
that's part of the reason why there is
no opposition to capital punishment even
though it's not terribly reasonable then
in the New Testament Christ wants us to
be merciful but he also is a God of
justice
so there's mercy but there's also
justice so at the same time when Christ
tells us go you know put away the sword
give away all of your possessions
he also says go right now and sell your
possessions sell your purse so that you
can buy not just one sword but two all
right and this kind of reminds us of how
that they're out there is a time for
every season under heaven there's a time
for peace and a time for war there's a
time for all of these things we don't
just have an ideology that that is
pacifistic that the Christianity is not
pacifistic and it's a shallow
Christianity that would pretend to be
pacifistic there's nothing good or
virtuous or moral about letting the
cruel rake the earth
nothing nothing right about that at all
the and when it comes to the Catholic
catechism it's true the Pope has used
very confusing language on this
he's used the word inadmissible but
that's certainly not been the case
throughout 2,000 years of Christianity
Thomas Aquinas defended killing heretics
using the power of the state to kill
heretics okay so as Thomas Aquinas now
in a Thema I don't think so
there can be a legitimate disagreement
over the death penalty among Christians
as Pope Benedict pointed out and let's
let's not be confused about that sort of
thing what the key to the death penalty
is is justice okay we think now that the
purpose of all criminal justice is
rehabilitation and deterrence those are
important aspects but the primary aspect
is retribution justice itself punishment
for violating the moral law for
violating the civil laws - that's the
key the purpose of it is justice
everything else Falls downstream of that
from Joshua the stock market and job
growth drops in any significant way can
trump still win in 2020 would he be able
to successfully make the election a
referendum on the Democrats devastating
economic policies in your opinion happy
new year if the economy collapses Trump
11 much harder time in 2020 luckily
there's no sign that the economy is
going to collapse I mean everybody says
we're due for a recession but you never
really do for a recession recessions are
caused by the economic cycle but they're
also caused by policies and fortunately
the economy has been going gangbusters
because of policies because the Trump
administration has come in and said now
we can get our manufacturing back we can
get consumer confidence up we can get
manufacturing confidence up things are
going really really well you know the
fewest federal regulations issued in 44
years that is a that is a really good
thing and so I would suspect as much as
you can predict these things I think
Trump is probably going to have a pretty
good economy going into 2020 but even if
it started to falter I think there is a
chance the Trump could still win based
on first principles I mean let's not
forget the misery index was pretty high
when Barack Obama got reelected
the power of the incumbency is is pretty
important and there's so much more going
on in terms of judges in terms of
culture in terms of national security
under Trump that he might have a little
leeway but still the economy is probably
gonna lead the
from Josh Michael what types of things
are going on in your earpiece during
your show Thanks it's pretty much just
like Hall and Oates
on repeat just kind of happy 1980s music
just to keep me all pepped up you know
ready to go obviously nothing
professionally important is ever going
on in my earpiece the minute they try to
tell me anything that actually has to do
with work I just just turn that down of
course from Johnny hey Michael love to
your show just wondering do you think
it's possible that we could legally
classified news sites such as CNN as
tabloids I was going to the store and it
struck me when I realized had tabloids
get away with publishing literal lies at
least from what I hear about celebrities
and how the media does the same thing
Thanks
yeah I mean I think it pretty much
already is considered tabloid news that
mainstream media CNN New York Times even
and I think those already are considered
tabloids what would be the legal
distinction though there really isn't
one we have very strong freedom of the
press in this country so we have very
weak libel laws it's very difficult to
successfully sue somebody for for libel
for defaming you and and so yeah the
mainstream media are gonna publish lies
all the time they publish lies about me
personally and that's just what they get
away with the key is exposing them as
you say as tabloids a shallow yellow
journalism and they I think that's
already happened I think that's probably
the defining feature of the Trump era is
the absolute just collapse of the press
and their credibility and that's a very
good thing all right last question from
Jairo hey Michael I'm in the US Army
I'll be deploying again soon after the
holidays I'm an avid reader and I love
books about US politics history
economics etc I was wondering if you had
a short list of books that you would
recommend for me to take with me or have
my wife sent me if possible very
respectfully hiram well first of all
thanks for your service I hope you have
a good deployment I do have
recommendations for books and actually
that timing worked out very well we're
about to launch a show with Prager you
in addition to this show but I will have
another show on Prager you called the
book club and we're gonna be going
through some of the most important books
that you should read we're going to one
a month we're starting that out this
month in January we're gonna begin with
man's search
for meaning by Viktor Frankl and that
guest on that episode is going to be
Damus Prague or the man himself so stay
tuned for that
I'll put out some lists of the books
that we're gonna be covering on that
show and you can read along with me and
then we'll be able to chat about it once
a month so stay tuned for that one of
the many things I'm excited for this
year that's our show I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show Happy
New Year everybody see you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis clever and Robert Stirling our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director hovel we douse key
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson hair
and makeup Jeshua alvera production
assistant McKenna waters the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you